today is andrew cuomo's last day as
governor of new york and it's a sad day
not because of the way he's leaving but
because of all the great work he's left
undone
so many staffers left unharassed so many
grandmothers left alive
free to play another round of checkers
at their nursing homes
and while he's packed up all his
belongings at the governor's mansion
he's reportedly leaving something behind
his dog
captain
a three-year-old siberian husky mix
according to reports the love gov is
begging mansion staffers to take the dog
off his hands
although his spokesman claims it's only
temporary
joining me now
host of the marc stein show
mark he's homeless
the governor doesn't have a home he's
he's out on the streets now and he's
asking for the maid to hold the dog
what's up
yeah this uh this dog the staffers don't
want it because the the dog apparently
uh just drags the staffers around in uh
in in the building uh just like the
governor right uh and the and cuomo says
that the uh the dog uh urinates all over
the carpet which is apparently just like
the governor too so they're more similar
than you than you might think but i was
just listening to the previous segment
and you know uh
what's his name dancing with chuck
schumer and i'm just reflecting on how
totally fake everything in politics is
now i was watching one of these
fire-breathing mullers
from kabul uh this morning and say what
you like about those guys but they seem
to be for real in american politics
i'm not advocating that they take over
here but compared to people whose dog is
a prop where even your pets are totally
fake and you know this dog is called
captain
and biden's dog is called major and i'm
willing to bet that some democrat focus
group has said you sound more
authoritative if you have a dog with a
military rank so if i ever run for
anything i'm going to have a dog like
that uh chief of staff millie guy i'm
going to have a dog called four star
general and he won't be able to catch
the cat because he'll be weighed down by
too many medals
everything is everything is utterly fake
and the only thing that isn't fake was
trump who was attacked for saying he
wasn't interested in having a white
house dog because he wouldn't have time
to look after the dog
i don't see
trump as a dog guy stroking a little
puppy on his lap watching tv off the
wing of the white house just don't see
it but that's him he wasn't a fraud and
he didn't like dogs he didn't
focus group
an admiral into his into his house so
you you see these images mark
you see if i was a republican this is
what i would do
i would put a little picture of chuck
dancing with colbert like
and i'd split screen it with the taliban
holding an american-made m4 surrounding
the kabul airport while americans are
stranded and i'll just say it's
priorities people
it's priorities we're stranding
americans while we're dancing here in
the streets
and that's fake news too because we all
know that chuck and that loser floppo
late night guy we all know they're not
real friends why are they pretending to
be dancing partners that's pathetic uh
the the proper relationship between
showbiz and politics is when uh sam
rayburn speak for the house in the 1950s
made the mistake of putting his hand on
frank sinatra's coat and frank said
hands off the thread street
this guy colbert is pathetic in not
doing the hands off the threads creep to
chuck schumer
who is a creep
well i think colbert needs to go work on
his monologue because gutfeld just
smoked him last week
get off the dance floor colbert get back
to work yeah you're falling behind 37
37 writers and he's got no jokes in the
monologue that's a fast that's right
imagine if i had 37 writers whoo
that'd be i need to talk to my agent
no you're you're you're pretty good just
with the uh the 26 guys that's right i
just need 26 and that's all i need all
right mark stein who doesn't need any
writers
not at all
it all comes straight from his crazy
brain thank you mark we appreciate it
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else